is Black Panther wakanda forever a
worthy follow-up to the original film or
does it fall short of Excellence here's
what the critics are saying it's
Premiere week for black panther wakanda
forever and members of the press have
attended special screening to the film
before they're allowed to get their
official reviews writers critics and
influencers take to social media to
share their initial reactions to the
project now that critics can expand on
those initial reactions we're getting
down into the nitty-gritty of black
panther wakanda forever there are still
some rave reviews for the flake but some
more negative responses are starting to
come through as of Tuesday November 8th
the Rotten Tomato score for black
panther wakanda forever has been
hovering in the mid 90s as these reviews
continue to Pile in this number will
rise and fall but it looks like critics
are absolutely loving the sequel but
it's not without its flaws as to be
expected many reviews mention the
emotional rollercoaster fans will ride
while watching wakanda forever deadlines
Pete Hammond said of the sequel there
can be no doubt coogler has meticulously
thought all of the sounds while still
delivering the rip roaring action
sequences and uncredited surprise
appearances we expect from any Marvel
movie but especially its Crown Jewel
coogler was praised in many reviews
which should come as quite a relief for
the director who had a tremendous amount
of pressure on his shoulders when making
this film according to Richard Roper of
the Chicago Sun Times black panther
wakanda forever quote succeeds as a new
adventure and is a tribute to a
wonderful actor who was taken from this
world decades too soon additionally
Jaime broadnax a black girl nerds is
calling wakanda forever the best film of
phase 4 making it the perfect film to
close out this segment to the Multiverse
Saga but while many critics are praising
the movie a nice chunk of them have some
quibbles with the movie's pacing in
Focus Richard Lawson of Vanity Fair
writes some will no doubt miss the tight
focus and energy of Black Panther the
sequel is more scattered a vast
expansion with a hole at its Center this
is a common theme among critics as many
suggest it doesn't stack up to its
predecessor to be fair black panther is
often hailed as one of the best
superhero movies of all time so it's not
an insult to say its sequel doesn't
match it Robbie Colin and the Daily
Telegraph held nothing back saying the
film is a near three-hour endurance run
of gloomy photography and urgently
staged emotionally empty two-way
conversation all seemingly designed the
sap cast and viewers combined will to
live Matt singer of screen Crush calls
the movie quote a messy sprawl of an
ensemble piece and says in his review
that watching the original before seeing
the sequel is a bad move because it
pales in comparison Rolling Stones K
Austin Collins offered a balanced
critique in his review writing the movie
isn't always on such sure footing but
that's almost appropriate a Messier
movie trying to reckon with a Messier
range of feelings when you left without
saying a word
you did
additionally some critics mention the
movie is just a little bit too long like
owing gliberman a varieties suggesting
20 minutes could have been shaved off
its 161 minute run time overall black
panther wakanda forever appears to be a
great addition to the ever expanding MCU
where it falls in the ranks is entirely
up to you but these reviews are any
indication it's definitely in the top
half Brian Truitt of USA Today wrote
director Ryan coogler delivers a
powerful follow-up to the phenomenal
2018 black panther that's funny clever
and heartbreaking impressive and it's
World building honest in its view of
world politics and naturally packed with
huge action sequences it definitely
seems like it'll help those suffering
from Marvel fatigue after the less than
Stellar Phase 4 Films like doctor
strange and the Multiverse of Madness
eternals and black widow cross bottom
line of collider added wakanda forever
isn't perfect but its ability to handle
this tight rope walk between exploration
of loss and a larger superhero film
makes this one of the most moving MCU
entries so far and one of the best films
to come out of Marvel space 4. according
to critics it sounds like coogler has
delivered a slightly messy compelling
sequel to the original film now all
that's left is to see what the fans
think when wakanda forever officially
premieres on November 11 2022